A business card is one of the most powerful but often ignored tools when you are marketing yourself.
They are inexpensive, yet indispensable.
They are like mini resumes that tell about you and what you are selling.
To include a descriptive catchphrase or tagline can work wonders.
What is interesting is that people are more likely to keep a business card with a photo on it.
These cards get attention!
It could be a photo of yourself or of something related to your area of expertise.
However, other people say that you should keep a business card simple.
A white background, simple font and no elaborate colors work best.
You should also make sure that your text and margins line up.
An uneven text looks messy and tells a lot about the person.
In any case, it's essential that you get your cards professionally done.